ladies and gentlemen our special guest
has made it and I know you're probably
just as surprised as I am from Conan and
Friends Conan O'Brien we got some
questions here that we were getting
through this Facebook live event
sponsored by Sam Adams here at backstage
beers with Conan and Rory Scovel you
want to you want a great question let's
make this a regular show by the way
backstage beers with Rory and Conan we'd
probably get free beer don't you think I
think we would get free beer with
situation are you or someone else is
interviewing you does it feel how does
it feel to be in the hot seat all of a
sudden you can catch a game that is way
too much no that's a loud slurp people
do that though right but when you're the
issuer I like slow and you interview you
must leave space for the guests I'm
teaching you okay you're young you're
the Wynwood I go for the sip maybe not
yet all right I'm gonna give you a
signal when to slurp you got it now see
on YouTube I already brought this up
they want to know your favorite employee
was of all time of all time oh man
that's a hard one I've had so many great
ones I think sonam obsessed you and my
assistant she's gotta be one of my
favorites is she the favorite I'm gonna
give it to sone Daniel just wants to
know what your favorite Batman movie is
my favorite Batman movie is the one from
the 1960s the Batman movie with Adam
West the real Batman
none of those gothic [ __ ] did I say go
ahead go ahead have yourself a nice
little quiet
hold on try that again
Joe on YouTube wants to know Conan who
is your favorite Simpsons character we
all know Conan invented the Simpsons
Conan invented the Simpsons I invented
the Simpsons didn't think it was going
anywhere after a couple seasons so not
only that I walk away sold his stock as
we didn't sell it I gave away my
ownership of the Simpsons I had like an
80% stake
they gave something to Matt graining for
doing some drawings I forget what he did
I gave it away I think those are the
those are the kind of moves you make you
know when you're young and you're just
playing cards and you say i'ma get me in
the biz yeah and I'm sure several people
told you that the show was gonna do
quite well for it was already doing
quite well there you go so I'm now in
terrible financial shape and Matt
Groening and a bunch of other people who
did nothing have it all you have a
pirate laughs thank you
and another compliment you have a pirate
laugh and a ski instructor sweater
it's an odd combination thanks for
joining us we have other cities go check
out team cocoa see if we're coming near
you